normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government
Florida rep Cory Mills flies to Israel
to rescue 32 Americans trapped amid
fighting but that was October 12th uh
that number is much much higher and it's
not just that you uh uh flew missions to
save people rescue people in Israel is
that Afghanistan as well right so uh I'd
like to start with Afghanistan if you
can talk talk to us about what happened
how it happened what what what prompted
you to actually line and start getting
some of these people out and then we can
get into obviously the Israel stuff so I
I get a call and I'd known Ronnie
Jackson for quite some time I mean this
is a guy who a rear Admiral who served
on the armed services committee who's a
a member of Congress and literally he
called me and said Corey I I've got a
problem he's like you know I've tried to
reach out to the state department I
tried to reach out to the Department of
Defense I've tried to see what we could
do to try and get some of my
constituents who are trapped in
Afghanistan who are being actively
hunted right now by the Taliban and and
I said well who is it you know and so he
disclosed who it was and it was a mother
and her three children you know a
15-year-old and 11-year-old little girl
a 15-year-old boy and a 2-year-old
little girl and uh he literally had no
idea how to get them out even though
here he is a member of Congress and he's
calling the right people who have
jurisdiction and approval on this
Authority and the things that they were
telling him was absolutely false they
would tell him oh well she can just call
the state department and they'll direct
her and she did this time and time again
to no answer or she would text them you
know just to give you an idea when when
and I told Ron I said look I'm going to
go over there I said and I won't come
back until I get them and that's one of
the things that he's said multiple times
and you know we were attempted to be
thwarted in our efforts by the Biden
Administration multiple times I mean
even had them scramble enough 16 to do a
fly over to try and intimidate us even
though we had approved Landing permits
on a PPR and we're in an American
aircraft with American former Special
Operations guys to save Americans and
it's our own government who's trying to
put us at risk but you know after 11
days we ended up conducting this this
successful Overland rescue which is the
first of its kind 2 and 1/2 weeks later
after Miriam and her children are all
already in in Amarillo Texas they're
already back in school she starts
receiving text messages from the state
department saying hey we're just
reaching out to you to see if you're
okay and find out where you're at in
Afghanistan they didn't even know that
she had been back safely I mean this is
the inept and fecklessness of this
Administration this is the Der elction
of Duty by secretary Lloyd Austin by
Anthony blink
the open borders under mayorcas the
weaponization under Garland and Ray I
mean all of these people need to be held
accountable but we don't do anything but
talk about we're more likely to oust
someone from our own party than to go
after the people who are actually
needing to be impeached I mean like
Bowman should be expelled for the for
the fire alarm thing but instead it's
George it's Santos who by the way is the
first person in history to not be
convicted of an actual crime and or
committed treason I mean look it's
happened five times before Santos three
people in 1861 which was right after the
Confederate you know that had that
deemed these individuals to be
treasonist and the other two who were
convicted felons and now you got a guy
who and this is why I voted against this
expulsion is that who are we to play
judge juror an executioner first off who
are we to not allow him due process to
be able to approach his accusers in his
day of court in front of a jury of his
peers because what this does in my
opinion is that I think that he has
every right to a potential appeal now
because I think that we have in some way
could potentially influenced the or Mis
or or started to lead the witnesses and
the jury in some way just by our actions
in Congress because now what we're
saying is is in America yeah you are
actually guilty until proven innocent
not innocent until proven guilty it's
going to Prejudice any jury pool because
this is National level Poli can the can
Congress just expel anybody at any time
if they vote on it technically they can
okay so it was LE everything that
happened was above board but it just
like yeah but he's not convicted it's a
weird precedent to
I mean we just decided that we don't
want you here anymore there's not an
actual crime you should have to run that
through the senate or at least by the
American people well and and let me be
clear I'm not trying to defend anything
that George Santos has done but what I
am defending is is the rights to do
process for every single American I mean
what kind of Precedence does this set it
was basically that's what we have to be
thinking about the house Ethics
Committee report and decision was enough
for everyone to say okay that's good
well it wasn't everyone not everyone but
for the enough people to say okay we
should expel unfortunately but you also
had people like a lot of the New Yorkers
who were in difficult positions because
since he's also from New York they felt
that they had to take action because
they were hearing it a lot from their
constituents but also here's my other
thing who are we in Congress to
basically make a decision to expel
someone who was elected by 750,000
people in their District yeah we should
allow the constituents to be able to do
their jobs and to be able to go ahead
and carry out their civic duties and
again this for me is more about
protecting your sixth amendment more
about protecting the rule of law you
know you know and and doe process but
also protecting the vote of constituents
so that they can actually have their
rights to elect or not elect whomever
they choose yeah it sounds like it's
become a little bit too much of a social
club of people that think they're Elite
and they can just I mean technically
they can still kick each other out but I
do think that that it's like you don't
like my guy well he's my guy well think
about it Jamal Bowman admits to doing
something wrong while a member of
Congress committing a crime and actually
is charged for that he gets censured a
guy who does something which was
previous in most cases of what his
indictments for the grand jury is being
accused of in my understanding is prior
to coming in and has not yet been
prosecuted for but he gets expelled is
it just legit we have Bowman on camera
if they were going to expel someone
before a conviction Bowman I would
understand as as being reasonable
because he's on camera I I don't even
justify that whether it's on camera or
not we should allow the due process to
be there we we can't say that we again
are being judged during an execution Bas
on our observance You Are Not Guilty by
the observations in which you make you
are guilty by the rendered Verdict by
either the Judgment of a judge who we
appoint for solid reasons or the jury
which actually finds their their peer
guilty I mean we just have to understand
We're a nation which is based on the
rule of law we're a constitutional
republic and we have to not continue to
water that down and dilute it just
because it's beneficial for us you've
got you brought up the the impeachment
of of secretary defense secretary
defense Lloyd Austin and he was resol he
was basically
largely responsible for the surrender of
the American Military the secretary of
state so what would an impeachment look
like what would be the charges and how
would that play out my my charge on him
was the D election of Duty I mean the
simple fact that he has a role to play
and a job to do you had soldiers who
were deployed who had no rules of
engagement no understanding of what
their authorization of force was I mean
there's people who could have actually
in in one case uh a guy named uh Tyler
Vargas Andrews I believe is his name or
Tyler Andrew Vargas always mess this up
um but he was uh badly injured uh and is
an ampute as a result of the explosion
he was the sniper who was in the tower
who actually had identified the
potential suicide bomber had called back
what he appeared to be the identificated
bolo which is the be on the lookout had
it verified was asking for a green light
to be able to engage and never receed a
green light from any of his command
because they didn't know who actually
had the authority to give that moments
later the explosion goes off 13 Brave
members have lost their lives the SE are
things where you should have an
escalation of force and Rules of
Engagement that's established prior to
them even being deployed you should have
an understanding of what was going on
and so this was completely just botched
from the very beginning and the fact
that there's no one who's been held
accountable and look when I think about
accountability I think about it as you
lead by example and so it's for me I
used to call it the concept of Windows
and mirrors when something is being done
properly and everything is going
successfully you look through the window
at all those outside who are actually
delivering on that but when something
goes wrong as a leader you have to look
in the mirror because ultimately it's on
you this seems like a pattern though I
mean there are several Republicans I
think Andy bigs and is it bigs or Briggs
from Arizona he brought der elction of
Duty impeachment uh charges against uh
mayorcas absolutely for the Border
because the B's a mess but I think
anyway can argue that's not no May Arcus
should definitely be impeached but we
haven't gotten it yet I mean there is
there are lots of members of the inid
administration who I would believe are
uh are derelict in duty but they are
still in office at what point do we get
some action I mean it must difficult
this is what frustrates me and obviously
you know the one thing that I agree with
is that we and the 11 18th Congress
brought back through our conference
rules the regular order which means that
everything has to go through its
Committee of jurisdiction and then come
out of that and then come to the house
floor but I mean look if we can't even
at least start the impeachment process
why can't we utilize things like the
Hing act where we basically take the
salary of those individuals and we drop
it down to $1 a year you know these
people shouldn't be getting paid when
they actually aren't doing the job that
they were actually put in place to do
and so until they can actually have an
impeachment inquiry and then trial and
be have have the depositions in place at
a minimum just like if a person in a
regular you know I think about this from
from the regular world if you do
something wrong in a job and they're
investigating what you did wrong in many
cases you get an ABS you basically get
leave you know uh from the job for a
certain period of time but you're not
being paid during that time you haven't
lost your job you can also go to jail
before you've been convicted that that's
exactly right see my whole point is is
that at least with the Homan rule we
could at least dropped his salary down
to $1 while we continue to investigate
and some
propos we could suspend Bowman pending a
conviction on the uh on the on the thing
with the doors the fire alarm very
possible what's the the home will they
and they won't that's that's the problem
I mean look you got someone on on on
camera committing a crime I think it's a
good point he should be convicted but at
the same time there's a reasonable step
between okay someone's been accused of a
crime there's a preponderance of
evidence that they may be violent so
we're going to hold them if they're if
they're found to be not guilty we rele
and we're supposed to have hearings for
this if there is someone who there is no
prance of evidence he's been accused
well then you don't even get an
indictment but if you do then the person
is going to be free on bail that's right
so considering Santos he's been accused
they say there's evidence okay well
you're going to have to prove that for
uh uh Bowman he lied about what he did
the camera proves he lied and he
committed a crime I would I would think
I would say it's fair to suspend him
pending a res a resolution this the
Homan rule so how do you enact to the
Homan rule uh it's essentially a
privilege resolution I believe that you
could put on the floor but uh uh last
time that we've actually well we've
tried it multiple times by a lot of us
who are true constitutional
conservatives who believe in
accountability of government and it
wouldn't get the votes okay so it's just
a one bill one vote kind of thing I mean
with some of these things like like I
mentioned uh potentially impeaching
aleandra maoris do you think there's a
point where Democrats would see yes the
border is a disaster I mean I think that
you even see that from New York city
mayor Adams right I me he's even crying
about it and these it's funny that now
the sanctuary cities oh come on in we're
inviting you in oh come on in are the
like this is actually a problem I mean
DC has said we need help but they
haven't actually well DC said they
needed help but only after we had to
pass things like the DC crime Bill to
stop the softon crime Catch and Release
policies of you know these woke and
these these liberal extreme Mayors like
Muriel Bowser or you know even even Eric
Adams or any of the rest but like my
whole point is is that there's more than
enough circumstantial evidence for us to
be able to move forward with impeachment
articles against if anyone anyone it's
secretary mayorcas because we get the
CBP reports I mean you're seeing the
record high numbers that are coming
across you're seeing an increase in the
number who are actually coming across
that are on terrorist watch lists I mean
this is the whole thing and this isn't
people from South America and that's
what people to understand you know 63 to
6,400 Afghans I mean 32,000 plus you
know Chinese from mainland China you've
got people from Yemen you've got people
from uh Saudi Arabia you got I mean
there there is a dozen plus different
countries who are coming through our
Southern borders and I don't think that
we can say the Secretary of my orcus is
doing anything to actually prevent that
because in fact he's the same one that
went on record to say we don't have open
borders right you know it just and the
bid Administration will say we're doing
the best job ever on the border well but
here's here's a great thing in the
hypocrisy of the bid Administration
they'll tell you that they had to repeal
remain in Mexico agreement or that they
had remove title 42 but then they'll
come back to you and say oh the entire
failed Afghan withdrawal we couldn't do
anything about it was already in motion
because of the Trump Administration you
know it it's just it the hypocrisy and
the lies that come out of this
Administration is just something I've
never seen in my lifetime yeah that if
they call it a failed withdraw they
should re retitle that a surrender
because that's what that was a
disgusting surrender to the strongest
military on Earth surrendered to the
Taliban not to mention the billions of
dollars that we left behind in weapons
defense articles and we put terrorist
organizations like the Taliban the
hakani network and Isis Corson in a
better position now than they're ever
were before and let let's go back why
did we go into Afghanistan 2001 it was
because we wanted to stop it from being
a safe haven or a harbor for terrorism
meanwhile fast forward to the Biden
Administration where we actually left
them after what I would argue still that
George W bush and even Obama had these
failed approaches that we can do nation
building which is not our role we're not
there to build the nation of others
we're there to basically eliminate
terrorists who are actually a threat to
America and come back home to protect
our homelands but you know let's fast
forward that to the point that we did
the opposite of what we said that we
were going there to do we actually
emboldened and strengthened and armed
and trained and even left enough cash to
create the cff if they want the opposite
of what the intent was that's why I'm I
I'm not satisfied with uh surrender I
think that's going too easy on them it I
don't I don't understand how you abandon
bam without informing the security
forces I think it's treas in what
they've done yeah I agree that again a
surrender would be like okay let let our
forces know we're we're out but
something else we have never we have
never pulled our military in our history
we've never pulled our military before
we ensured the safety of civilians first
I mean the idea that we're going to pull
our military before we even try and make
sure that American citizens are out
first to be saved but why but the BM
thing gets me because we doctr we could
have evacuated through bam absolutely we
could have Okay so let's say and I've
been to Bam multiple times you you could
have here's the other big thing that you
have to understand we could have
simultaneously run two separate airports
right you could allowed the continu
station of the civilian uh hkaya that
was going on and you could have gone
ahead and utilized bam which by the way
could have housed 40 plus thousand
people we could have done the necessary
biometric Health scans to look at our
sivs and others who actually had served
with us for over 20 plus years risking
their lives instead of just abandoning
and leaving them behind who are being
now methodically killed you know one by
one but the other thing is that what did
it have it had an entire military
installation of parameter standoff so
what ended up happening and this is
where the Biden Administration hasn't
been answering for this yet when they
shut down bogam to hand it over to China
and they went ahead and allowed the BM
prison which released over 40,000
terrorists who are actually already been
incarcerated there to be released yes
who had been which basically plused up
the entire force that was already coming
in now what else did you do when you
take a military takeover of a civilian
uh uh airport all of those flights
because they were telling all the
Americans you have to be out by
September 11th he wanted to tout this
great Victory on this day but when he
shut it down premature to that all the
people who had Ian flights out on Ariana
cam air Emirates you name it those air
liners got completely canceled so there
was no more calm air that could come in
come out so they essentially entrapped
Americans by shutting down the civilian
airport and giving them no Safe Harbor
to be able to get out I I pulled up the
name it's Tyler Vargas Andrews he's the
dude absolute hero he was in a tower you
were saying and then they were
surrounded or they were people coming at
them they had already been told that day
of what the bolo was which is beyond the
lookout of the individual what he'd be
wearing what he be carrying a satchel
you know these types of things he while
he was up there in the tower identified
an individual who fit that description
who he believes is the actual bomber the
suicide bomber he then relay that
information back and someone came to the
tower to confirm exactly what he saw
from I believe it was the scaps
Battalion that was there and they
confirmed what he saw and then he asked
for green light to engage and no one in
his command or even at higher command
knew who could actually provide that
Authority so no one gave him the
Authority moments later explosion occurs
and we saw what happened first thing he
did a show on with Shawn Ryan it's
spectacular and Tyler's awesome and it's
like five and a half hours long and
everyone should go watch that the guy's
amazing so is this like obsessive
centralized Control Authority thing like
new is it normal because I would think
you'd have somewhere in the lower levels
of command that are like at least
equipped to give you an order or to
respond to your request for for Action
well you usually in every scenario I've
ever seen you always have command who
can actually issue that Authority and
you always have an clear understanding
of what your Rules of Engagement are
what the escalation of forces is and the
bottom line is is that this was AA a
chaotic botched withdrawal that
endangered American lives and I can tell
you that secretary blinkin was even
given a cable a diplomatic cable with 23
members of The Diplomatic Corp who
warned him about this strategy saying
Americans would die
they tried to hide that from our Foreign
Affairs committee until the point that
we actually were trying to subpoena uh
chairman McCall was subpoena Anthony
blinkin for the fact that he wouldn't
and refused without the redacted lines
on it which was basically the entire
document to show this but here's what we
ended up asking we asked a woman who had
been responsible for filing those types
of cables and we said and your entire
time and she was almost done with her
career I think she had 17 plus years
have you ever seen how many of these
cables do you get a year what they call
a descent cable and she said somewhere
between maybe one to a year on average
and we said okay great how many people
usually are signatories on these
documents and they said one maybe two
people and I said so it didn't send a
red flag when you had
23 people who are part of the Diplomatic
core of the state department who signed
this descent cable warning about this
withdrawal prior to it happening so all
the signs were there all the intel was
there there was Intel reports by the way
that even demonstrated who and when and
what was going to happen they even I
mean to the point where the before they
would say okay these individuals are
moving from this city to this city next
day they're now in the city next day
they're in a planning phase next day
they're now done with the plan here's
how it's going to be carried out and
then boom the next day occurred so blink
and Austin can't say that they didn't
have the details and the information on
how to prevent this they are responsible
and there's blood on their hands and
there has to be accountability I I don't
think it's a strategy I I don't see any
reasonable argument for abandoning bom
it doesn't it doesn't make sense it it
do the only reason you would do that is
to create chaos disorder and
intentionally get people killed or
unless China and others are trying to
tell you that you need to go right now
because you're a compromised and
corrupted Administration and you're now
leaving by the way $1.1 trillion in
lithium so you think sitting in panser
you think there's comprom on Biden or
the administration China says we're
taking the base we're taking the country
and you're getting the F out who was the
first person who recognizes Taliban is
an actual form of government Chinese
China's moving in they're going for the
lithium mines 100% I it it could also be
it could be it could be comom but could
it also be Biden just selling think
about it though for a minute just put
this together you're now handing over a
country putting Americans at lives so
that the the Chinese can get to $1.1
trillion in in potential lithium and at
the same time what are you pushing for
you're pushing for an EV system which is
based out of lithium Cobalt and nickel
which is all produced by China to build
their economy the these are not and this
is where you know being a geopolitical
analyst for a long time you don't look
at everything so singularly you start
making the link analysis of look this is
not a one-off look and and you know this
it's not just kind of this coincidence
you know in police work they call them
Clues and so what we have to understand
is is that that's exactly what is going
on is that we are driven towards
building China's economy and going to a
more China One you know foreign first
policy as opposed to an America First
policy where we actually look out for
our own and that's that's because of the
corruption and that's because of what
you're seeing being released by chairman
James comr chairman Jim Jordan chairman
uh uh Jason Smith where they're showing
the multitude of layers of corruption
and the spiderwebs of companies and the
continuation of this 10% for the big guy
and the millions upon millions of
dollars that Jim and Haley and Hunter
and all them are getting look the this
is the most corrupt and most bought and
paid for pay forplay Administration that
I've ever seen in my lifetime so what do
we do man we impeach his ass Joe Biden
I'm down we hold accountability we
return the power back to the American
people we start actually being true
constitutionalists who understand that
our overspending which in my I've talked
about this previous when we were on the
you know going into the show but you
know we're running into an economic
abyss and we keep acting like we can cut
our way to Prosperity you can't ask any
business owner out there if you can cut
your way to profitability you can't your
account receivables have to exceed your
account payables and if they don't then
you're insolvent as a business the
difference is as a business when you
have to go and get a line of credit or
you have to go to a bank you have to
prove your ability to actually pay it
back well American government does is
they utilize the American people as a
taxpayer who is the bank but they don't
have to justify how they actually pay it
back they don't have to actually show a
business plan on what they're actually
doing and they think they can cut their
way to Prosperity as opposed to focusing
on what they need to which is proper
reform on the nearly 73% of mandatory
spending that is going on understanding
you have to have a cut strategy which
yes that is part of it to try and make
sure that programs and things that we're
spending on is no longer you know doing
their purpose or serving their purpose
is eliminated ated but also an economic
growth strategy that allows us to
understand how do we get that GDP to
national debt inverted ratio back to a
point where we could even be stable one
but also where we can back it by
tangible assets that allow our dollar
and our currency to have confidence
across the global market for even the
developing nations that are utilizing it
who's co-sponsoring your impeachment
Bill uh with the uh Lloyd Austin yeah we
had quite a few signatures on there yeah
anyone who you want weren't expecting to
jump on no actually it's exactly the
type of America First conserves that you
would imagine you gave me some crazy
numbers before we went live about what
our dollar every dollar the government
borrows it's what 70 so this continues
to change obviously as as you know every
second we get more but essentially think
about it from this perspective right
when you hear your representative or
your Senator talk about how they're
making the biggest cuts ever to spending
I want to get an understanding of what
that means every dollar that we borrow
roughly 73 cents of that we'll call it
70 cents 70 cents of that is spent
already just on the mandatory spendings
and then as our debt continues to
increase as the actual interest rates on
that debt continues to increase roughly
right now around 11 cents of every
single dollar is just servicing our
interest payments and then you look at
our defense spending which I think we
can argue you know with with good
understanding that we need a strong
military that's 13 14 cents of every
dollar you know at 800 60 to 870 billion
that we're spending on our military per
year which is needed because we don't
even have our our necessary classes for
the Columbus class and things like that
for our submarines and others but that's
spent just about which means that your
representative your Senator the person
that's telling you we making these
massive Cuts what they're talking about
is we're taking a 20% a 30% cut yeah
you're right a 20 to 30% cut on the
remaining nine cents or so that you can
actually touch which in the scheme of
things those cents that you're cutting
on that is not going to get us again
you're not cutting your way to
Prosperity without having an economic
growth strategy without decoupling
ourselves aders away from the
adversarial Nations without getting
control of our supply chain our
resources and rare earth minerals that
are necessary for us to support an
industrial based buildout we're not
going to be able to do this based on DC
status quo that we're going to spend our
way out of this or we're going to be cut
our way to prosperity it's a lie the you
you the numbers add up to like 95% of
every dollar we borrow is autom atically
spent so of that less five these are
rough numbers of the remaining 5% if
they cut 20% of that 5 cents and it's
like 1 cent or less you're still not
getting your way to a way of prosperity
and they'll tell people they're cutting
20% of the of the budget of the of the
spending but it's only F of the five
cents on a dollar they're cutting 20% of
the 5 cents that's that's like less than
five t0 of a cent I don't percent like
okay so that's crazy now let's talk
about GDP growth you told me before the
show you believe it's energy I think
it's energy I think we should transition
it into a hydrogen-based fuel economy
I'm I'm bullish on this coming out of
Rice University they're making hydrogen
gas out of recovered carbon trash hit it
with electricity at 7,000 degrees they
flash it turn it into hydrogen fuel
they're left over with $4.50 so let's
jump that though how many how many oil
refineries are in the United States Cory
might know better than I do we haven't
built an oil refinery since like the
1970s no no but but yeah but how many do
we have I think what two or three that's
it it I think so then I's idea stand I I
really could I really don't know the
exact number on that but uh I can tell
you that we haven't built a Refinery
since I believe it was the 70s but the
bottom line is that here's the issue I I
don't think that's an either or and you
always hear this from the left and the
right you know I'm all for the idea of
drill baby drill look trust me I I like
the idea of continuing to produce fossil
fuels looking at LNG uh I like the idea
of us basically continue to look and
explore Renewables looking at nuclear
which by the way is the cleanest safest
everyone wants to argue 9M Island or
Chernobyl or you know the the uh issue
that happened in in the I can't remember
the name of the Japanese reactor that
Wasim I got a fact check for you yeah
the last refiner was built in February
2022 there are currently 129 operating
in the United States that's that's a lot
more than I actually anticipated but it
does look like it's you know maybe one
every decade or so one every uh eight
years what do they say it definitely
doesn't keep up with our current growth
and what our utilization is I mean but
but going back to my point of the
renewable reliable argument it it has to
be both we have to be able to look at
multiple things but we have to
understand that if we're going to
basically go off of this you know gold
standard which we did I believe it was
around 1971 or 1973 I can't recall and
go to the Petro dollar that dollar has
to be backed by some type of a tangible
production and that right there because
to your point on the GDP we had passed
hr1 which was a bill that Steve scales
put onto the floor which is the lowcost
energy act which basically gets us back
to a more energy dominant position but
at the same time we passed hr21 which
would prevent the president from
draining down our strategic petroleum
reserves that he has actually done at a
record level that we've never seen
before so if we go to this and we start
actually producing energy and we back
our Dollar by this in the way that we
should then every single time if
especially if we look at energy output
because I agree with you Ian and this
the Global Currency which is the whole
point China Russia Iran and North Korea
have continued to modify their
constitution to stay in power forever
because they want to do what they want
to eliminate the US dollar from the
Global Currency they want to throw us on
hyperinflation they want to the
corruption of wh and wef who by the way
I co-sponsor the bill with chip Roy that
would actually stop us from directly or
indirectly even funding any of the who I
think it's a complete you know uh farce
but my whole thing is is that we have to
start basing our valuation our spending
cap on what our energy production is
which also would incentivize every
president on the left and the right to
produce as much as possible to have the
most spending levers but it would weaken
OPEC who when they try and threaten us
and say we're cutting our production by
100,000 barrels we go oh oh great so the
price of oil goes up we have more money
to spend great thanks for that so my
whole thing is you decouple away from
the utilization but also things like us
Aid where we continue to utilize cash
diplomacy where we're sending for
example $800 million to a country that
absolutely hates us and we think that's
going to turn around and they're going
to go you know what we love you now
America no they're going to say we still
hate you but we're $800 million on
taxpayers money richer well like divorce
dads trying to bribe kids and Ling us
correct and not only that but think
about it and I don't like to to to build
up any thing that another nation is
doing that's kind of an adversary of us
but what Russia did with Germany was
convince them to get rid of after 20
years all their nuclear and Coal Energy
and be completely dependent upon them we
could actually stop cash diplomacy under
us Aid Supply lowcost reliable energy to
developing nations which would also
ensure that they continue to stay on
side with America but also guess what
it's Revenue coming into the US it's not
us pouring tax money dollars into
another nation and continue to send
things out yeah the Petro dollar needs
to be converted do a hydrogen dollar I I
know we can do it and the oil Industries
all you execs out there listening will
turn your oil into graphine we're not
going to stop drilling it's going to get
even better okay so so the reason I
asked about how many refineries there
were is because first before we're going
to transition the US economy in from oil
to hydrogen you need comparable energy
production for which you were able to do
it true right now one of the big
challenges with electric vehicles for
instance is charging them and so uh what
what you hear a lot about is
batteries what's the range on the
vehicle actually range is no issue for
us so with the Tesla you you park it you
charge it you never drive far enough to
where we even care about what the charge
is because once you bring it home it's
charging the issue is if you want to
travel far you need to be able to refill
it very quickly so you do need Good
batteries but uh so so adoption is going
to be is going to come from expansion
technology now as for like hydrogen
fuels and fusion or anything else
someone's going to have to be able to
run their car off of hydrogen hydrogen
energy which is go which is going going
to require an EV we are not even at the
point where people can use EVS Rel ibly
because gas you fill up your car in 30
seconds some way safely right because we
saw where like in Florida for example we
were having floods and these batteries
were essentially they were blowing up
endangering people so we we really need
to think about also just the safety and
reliability and and Ronnie Jackson said
this the best he said look it's a simple
thing I'll take reliable over renewable
and and and again I think that it has to
be both I think we have to be able to
have an understanding and a choice for
every single americ which why you know
we just voted down by the way you know
the bid wanted to force every American
by
2032 to go completely to EV and luckily
we in the house I don't know what the
Senate will do with this we voted it
down because we believe that just like
whether it's medical Freedom whether
it's school choice whether it's we are
supposed to be providing Freedom Liberty
and protection of the rights of every
American people not telling them you
need more government in your life the
the issue with the Renewables is that
they're as you described not as reliable
so with uh chemical energy with
petroleum the reason why I don't see the
US getting off of a a petroleum economy
is because it is a dense extremely dense
chemical storage of energy which can be
utilized whenever yeah it's fuel there's
only three elements that can function as
fuel it's hydrogen carbon and um
plutonium and so we're using the carbon
in the oil but we can use the hydrogen
fuel it's just transportable if you can
put it in a box and move it around it
becomes a fuel like producing steam is
not fuel but but the issue is with you
know so so there's theoretically cell
you can do hydrogen tanks in cars and if
those could charge the batteries and so
but but you no you could do hydrogen
combustion Vehicles which people have
and they're really cheap to operate or
or natural gas uh cars and then you need
to retrofit every single gas station and
you need to build the refineries or you
can build engines that are hybrid
hydrogen petroleum engines and so you
could use either I think that's where
we're going the day you know what I want
I want people to be able to heat and
cool their houses at a fraction of what
they're using right now I want fuel
prices for whatever it is that you drive
to be affordable for every single
individual and I want us to get away
from the idea that we're continuing to
stay reliant on adversarial Nations how
we get there I don't I'm I'm less
concerned with as much as needing to get
there and finding the solutions I want
to jump to the story from baren US
military holds exercises exercises in
Guyana as border tensions sore oh boy
I'm glad the US is down there as
Venezuela is building up its military on
their Eastern Front because they're
claiming basically half the country of
Guyana as their territory why Exxon
discovered a bunch of oil so the US of
course is down there Guyana has asked
for us uh the us to help prevent a
Venezuelan invasion of Guyana Venezuela
of course just sees dollar signs well
not necessarily dollar signs one of the
wealthy they're the most resource
wealthy in South America they got oil
Venezuela now they want to steal more so
I guess the two big issues here are
welcome to the issue of you're never
going to get off oil because it is just
too valuable it is it is it is Rel
relative to hydrogen or nuclear it's
easy to get it's easy to use it you can
it can be stored in Easy containers it
is absolutely amazing and I don't want
to get off of it I just want to build
alternate systems that we can use in
conjunction with it cuz Plastics I mean
I don't I mean maybe we can make better
Plastics with carbon but with graphine
you know you can upscale these things
into better materials but oil is
incredible it is very valuable right and
but so the subject I want to get into is
uh you think we're going to get into
another War you think war is spreading
out of South America look I I would say
that weakness invites aggression and we
have to acknowledge that the Biden
Administration has continued to
demonstrate this weakness in the world
stage which is why we are where we are I
think that all of our enemies and our
adversarial Nations again you know if
you go back I I wrote about this years
ago about the Russia China Iran and
North Korea and geopolitical Alignment
you know they're utilizing not just
their uh alignment to try and go ahead
and expand out the belt and Road
initiative or to take the 15 of 16 rare
Earth mineral mines but to expose us and
drag us into these Quagmire Wars where
we can continue to drain down on what we
have as far as defense articles within
our own storage capacity and
capabilities what are they're they're
testing for their own intelligence what
our industrial base can actually
withstand with regards to production
capacity and capability and whether we
could actually you know stand up to an
actual large scale uh War but they're
continuing to also drag us into areas
because think about it Venezuela is
partnered in its a marriage of
convenience with Russia we were actually
starting to focus a lot on the belt and
Road initiative expansion by looking at
certain types of a sanction or looking
at certain types of a internationally
recommended Transit Corridor for supply
chain stuff what what what China is
trying to achieve is this and that's why
and it does play into this and I I'll
explain this how they essentially want
to take this belt and Road initiative
which expands the Eurasian border takes
Africa and Oceania and that would cut
off Western Hemisphere supply chain
whether it's the Red Sea Mediterranean
Black Sea Persian Gulf corner of Africa
while simultaneously utilizing this
marriage convenience with Russia to take
Venezuela with the shabas of Venezuela
Pedro and Colombia and then look look at
economic coercion in countries like
Panama and Honduras so they can actually
also start taking over the trade tariff
taxes and everything on the Panama Canal
so they could also pinch us there but
they had to draw us away from what they
were doing in that belt and Road
initiative by actually focusing in our
own Western Hemisphere I mean look
they're also in addition to all the
things that's going on here they are
also building up the largest joint
training spy Base in Cuba which is an
impact to me as a Florida resident who
is 90 Mi off my Shore and so this issue
that we're seeing in Venezuela is
nothing more than that continuation of
that belt and Road initiative or that
geopolitical alignment between China and
Russia where they're trying to draw us
into more of this while they continue to
do a resource grab and to your point
earlier to tie this in a bow that's
because it's not about the US dollar as
the global currency or the real or the
dinar or the Yen or the ruble or
whatever energy is the global currency
and who has the most wins specifically
fuel it's fuel because energy can be
produced locally but can't be
transported like nuclear power plants
can't transport properly to Afghanistan
whereas fuel can be picked up lifted and
moved pretty simple get our GDP to
national debt ratio inverted secure our
borders stop the wokeism get our
industrial base build out start thinking
about energy dominance we have to start
just thinking about the priorities of of
government do you think that the US
could handle a large scale War right now
I think that we could handle a large
scale War but I don't think that America
is ready for a large scale War what
distinction are you making well I look
at what our industrial based capacity
and capabilities are as far as buildout
I look at the fact that we're already
spread so thin and trying to continue to
this as I talked at and I kind of
ridiculed which rightfully so in my
opinion this neoconservative neoliberal
1980s style you know of of
interventionist ideologies that we have
to be involved in every war and we have
to actually go and make it from a
kinetic perspective um I I think that we
showed our hand the other day whenever
and I voted against it obviously but we
voted on sending cluster Munitions over
to to Ukraine do you know why we
actually were starting to dump our
storage with cluster ammunitions because
and this is something that's been banned
by over 100 different nations because
you have a roughly one to 5% I know it's
a wide range but depending on the
producer 1 to 5% dud ratio which means
that you have more uxo which means
you're going to have larger civilian
casualties at at the end of it and so we
stopped utilizing the Clusters but we
did that because our industrial based
with the resources and you know the
capabilities couldn't keep up with what
was necessary for the high Mars and
attack thems and the other areas for5
artillery shells things like this and
we're starting to get into what we call
our taming requirement which is our own
munition requirements and starting to
drill into that and so you know we're
showing and again this is the Brilliance
of what China and others are doing which
is that they're exposing some of the
weaknesses by dragging us into Wars that
they're not paying a dime on to try and
go ahead and look at where our
weaknesses are so that if they do choose
to take Taiwan or they do Tres to go
ahead and bring us into the Western
Hemisphere into Guyana or to into these
things that we actually they know what
our capabil capacities are and so um you
know we have to be better and we also
have to understand domestic and foreign
policy is intrinsically linked what we
do domestically impacts us
internationally and vice versa and so
it's really important for us to try and
understand that we have to get our
supply chain back we have to get our
resources back we have to start actually
harvesting oursel I personally am a big
fan of the idea of doing deep seabed
harvesting you know the Earth is 70%
water and there are more natural
resources not talking about drilling
just talking about deep seabed
harvesting mineral harvesting there is
more at the 10,000 12,000 meter depth
levels than what you could find in these
15 of 16 rare Minal Minds that China has
and China by the way controls 100% of
maganese production across the world
were you sorry I'm going to Pivot
slightly but were you always a
conservative or did your time in the
military sort of shift your perspective
I have been a registered Republican my
whole life and a constitutionalist my
whole life you know look I I tell people
all the time the only reason I'm a
registered Republican is because we're
stuck in this two- party system and
that's the one that essentially is the
closest to my conservative values right
it's not 100% aligned I think that we've
gotten away from theity you have
registered uh registered with a party to
vote in a primary in Florida no I mean I
grew up Connecticut and you did so I
registered as repic a lot of npas they
are excluded from primaries but my
reasoning was is that you know there was
times when we actually had great
Republican members you know we still
have some today not to say that we don't
but I also think that what and you know
we're seeing a mass exodus by the way
you know of members from Congress it's
weird but it's actually you know I I
think it's a good thing and I'll tell
you why it doesn't sound good because it
doesn't have the numbers that we need
but we're ushering in a new generation
of conservative and we have evolved back
to the ways of being a true
constitutionalist being a fiscal
conservative understanding that we
represent the American people being a
Statesman not a politician look I've
been called almost everything in the
world the most derogatory term that you
can call me as a politician so you know
my whole thing is I just want to get
back to We the People and I think the
only way you do that is through limited
government and an understanding of what
actually is the America for his agenda
and so this is where president Trump and
I've endorsed him from a long time ago
um I believe he's exactly what we need
in the nation right now to get us back
on track to make those bold course
Corrections yeah you said deep resour
deep sea resource harvesting deep sea
does that work is that like with drones
you can do it with drones and here's the
great part I still think that we should
be utilizing the quantum space where you
know for example do you remember when
Reagan had bankrupted the Soviet Union
with the Space Race no I didn't know he
did that yeah so we should be also
thinking about the idea of how can we
actually get China involved in a in a
Quantum race whereby they also because
their economy is worse than ours it's
just that the reason that people still
prop up their currency is because they
don't allow their books to be audited
they lie about what they actually spend
and what they actually have and so we
could try and corrupt and bankrupt or
corrupt we should try and bankrupt them
through a Quantum race whereby you know
being the first to have ai self-healing
autonomous drumes utilizing like Quantum
linkage you know would be something that
we were trying to advance in you know
again the idea is is that if you could
get something in a swarm drone
technology through uh Quantum linkage
that uh essentially is beneath their
satellites but above their uh GSM Tower
providers you could kind of leave
someone blind deff and dumb on the
battlefield create to communicate
through crystals so you know the idea is
that I think that there's ways for us to
start thinking about and this this is
why I argue again it's not just looking
at kinetic Warfare but it's thinking
about the ideas of economic resource
supply chain cyber and Quantum races
that is the actual way not to include or
not to not to miss out the fact that
it's also the information and propaganda
and information campaigns that going on
what makes me nervous with qu with
artificial intelligence autonomous
drones with weapons as if they get
hacked I mean obviously that's the the
threat and and I'm sure China's going
through the same thing right now but the
thing is I guess whoever builds it first
and if you've got Quantum encryption you
know the quantum encryption race also is
insane because whoever gets that can
crack open all the bank records of
everyone in the country and release them
all the next the speed in which and the
capacity of quantum data Computing is
just but I I agree with you we do need
that race cuz it's dangerous to have
autonomous artificial intelligent drones
with lasers but there's that's where
it's headed so like we need to win the
race yeah that quantum entanglement that
that that everyone's trying to rush
towards I want to ask you if you
expected Kevin McCarthy to resign I
actually didn't I I didn't know it was
going to take him this long yeah so you
were like well he's saying end of the
month no no what I'm wondering is like
did you guys have a poll going and you
were like well we we they did the
squares we wer we weren't doing calendar
Bingo but I I I can tell you that yeah I
assume
against the rules or because no no just
because I well we had do when when it
was announced was the was the pizza
party uh held for lunch or
dinner I I I I I think instead of a
pizza party everyone was probably
there's probably quite a few offices
that was uh a toasting and cheering and
I don't think anybody honestly I don't
nobody car like the news broke and we
kind of just Shrugged and then again you
have people who are still in office
right now who are just a we still want
him a speaker we're not willing to give
up we're not I mean so too bad and
McKenry announced the day before and
they were supposed to be sort of allies
right so it seems like there is an exit
like an like Patrick you know Patrick
McKenry he was always getting ready I
mean he's at the end of his his ability
for chairmanship and the financial
services anyway but a really smart guy I
mean truly truly a smart guy um I mean
he still has another year to go he
doesn't leave no he's not going to just
try and abandon the seat um you know
I'll tell you though and and they can
think what they want but I thought the
the tweet that broke the cycle for me uh
few days ago was by Matt Gates when he
tweeted out Mick
L Mick L yeah it was like a little
tagline you saw the the community note
on his tweet saying like where he was
like I will never quit and then it was
Community not said he just quit oh
that's Community note on his tweet
saying he wouldn't was he disliked I
mean this is all anecdotal I don't know
if you can really answer he point a lot
of people to like him so I mean did or
did I me every's really nice guy like
cool and personable in person but just
wasn't getting the job done well look no
no he was getting the job done for for
the other people for the corporations
and for the lobbyists right well you
know at the end of the day I think that
if we could have actually achieved what
we had originally agreed upon in the
first conference rule agreements you
know when we came out where we are going
to do regular order we are going to have
certain priorities of you know getting
things done for for me what really just
kind of uh broke confidence and
capabilities was when we had the debt
ceiling debate you know I was all for
the idea once we had gotten permanent
reform in place and the Reigns act would
stop overregulation of the private
sector and we had a very fixed number at
1.47 one of spending cap which would
have been a very good spending level
because that would have been pre-co
pre-emergency 2019 spending levels I
understood the intent of that because we
were going to try and do a policy writer
with hr2 to also secure our borders when
we appr approved that we got that passed
when it went to the Senate and what came
back was that absolute just complete
acques with the physical what they call
physical responsibility which is
physical irresponsibility act that
basically took the 20 plus permit
reforms down to four that stripped out
cat cck's Reigns act which would have
stopped because I'm one of those odd
individuals who believe that the private
sector should be driving policy more so
than policy driving the private sector
but also the fact is is that it's not as
if we have a lack of legislation we have
a lack of the ability and the
willingness to enforce existing
legislation but every single member of
Congress wants their name on a p on on a
piece of legislation everyone wants to
try and play political football instead
of going back and looking at certain
bills that no longer serve their
purposes in looking at reforms as
opposed to just continuations of these
vague and AR ambiguous you know bills
that get passed that won't serve its
overarching purp or has no Sunset clause
in it where we would actually have to be
forced to reevaluate it and so I could
go on and on and on look I I this is my
first full year in January that I've
been in Congress but I can tell you that
it was a lot more of a broken
institution than I even understood when
I was running for congress and I think
that we have taken this entire time many
of us who are in there who are true
constitutionalist to try and bring back
what con our Constitution and what our
actual Congress is supposed to be doing
and and and an old saying that I've
heard recently which I love which is
that you know change in the beginning
it's very hard thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 p.m. and become a member over at
timcast.net